So, let's remember how we defined our ranking function.
So, we said we're going to have a time
step. We're going to keep going through steps to
get more accurate rankings. But initially, we're going to give
every rank 1 divided by the number of pages. Before I called that
capital N. I'm going to use npages as a more Pythonic variable name for that.
And we updated the rank at time step t by adding
the probability that the random surfer starts over and
randomly picks that page. So, that's 1 minus d,
is the probability of starting over, divided by npages,
how many pages there are. And remember that d
is our damping constant, and we'll decide that d
is 0.8. That's the damping constant. We add to
that the sum that we get of all the ranks, all the pages that link to this URL.
We add up d times the previous iterations. So,
it's going to be d times rank on step t minus
1 of that page. But we want to divide that by
the number of outlinks from p. So, it's starting
to look more like Python code. We want to simplify
it a little bit before we get to Python code.
And the first thing we're going to do to simplify
it, is observe that. Well, we have this t parameter.
But we only ever use the very previous one. So, we
don't really need to keep track of the rank value for
all of the different t values. We just need to keep
track of the previous one. When we did Fibonacci, we kept
track of current and next in variables. And that allowed us
to keep track of the previous and the previous previous Fibonacci
numbers. What we want to do with ranks is something similar.
So, we're going to use the variable ranks to keep track of
the current ranks. And as we compute the new
ranks, we're going to use the variable newranks. So, we'll
use ranks, this corresponds to the ranks at time
t minus 1, the ranks of the previous iteration.
And we'll have a variable newranks, which is the
ranks at time t. And the reason we need
both of those. As we update the rank from
each page. So we're going to go through the pages,
recomputing its rank. We can't lose the previous one. We
still need to get rank at the previous step for that
page. If we use the one that we got this time,
that would distort the results. It would mean that the order
that we update the ranks for changes the results. So, we
don't want the results to depend on the order that we
go through the pages. That's why we need to keep track
of both the previous values, which will be used for ranks
t minus 1 and the newranks. Once we have
done that, we don't need the t parameter anymore.
What we are going to do is change this rank,
the rank at time t is going to be the value
of newranks. And the value of rank at time
t minus 1, that's the value of ranks. The other
change I slipped into this. Before we had parentheses
here and I've changed them to square brackets. And square,
square brackets should give you the idea that well, this might
be a data structure that we're indexing. And that's correct. We
want to index the data structure. And we want to index
it by the URL that we're looking for. And the Python dictionary
provides a great way to do that. At the end of
this will be a Python dictionary. And that's exactly what we want.
So, I think we're ready to start looking at the code.
We've written this formula. It's still a mix of math and Python.
But we're going to turn this into the code for computing the page ranks.